e
okay good morning we'll call the fiscal
committee meeting to order for Thursday
June
20th and note that we have some
Replacements um for for the Senate side
Senator award is replacing Senator gray
Senator Lang is replacing Senator
Bradley and I guess we'll expect uh
Senator dallesandro
momentarily okay first item is
acceptance of the minutes of May 17th I
understand there'll be some ex some
extensions for those who were not here
moved by Senator Rosenwald second by
second uh Senator Le represent
lean any any changes or additions to the
minutes
seeing none are you ready for the motion
to accept the minutes of May 17th all in
favor say I oppose no extensions one
two okay moving on to tab two old
business there is not none tab
um okay tab three was we didn't have
anything
there now tab three is is is the
beginning of the consent
calendar there are three items removed
from the consent calendar under tab
three items
24228 and
24230 both with Department of Health and
Human Services and under Tab 4
24227 again the Department of Health and
Human Services I'll entertain a motion
to adopt the rest of the
current uh consent calendar minus those
three that I just
mentioned motion by Senator dallesandro
second by Senator um Lang to accept the
rest of the consent calendar so we'll
move on now to under tab
three all in favor say I I oppose no
motion is adopted
you moving on to number
24228 welcome the financial officer Mr
White and who else have some more people
I'm Karen Heber director for the
division of economic stability at DHHS
thank you uh representative F had a
questions on this representative Edwards
first thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I I don't have a
problem with the transfer I I just want
to dip into the eligibility system
question in a couple of ways uh one um I
I think DHHS overall uses uh New Heights
as an eligibility system and I'm reading
that there's another system involved
verify current income that sounds like
another it system I
I why am I confused are there are there
more than one eligibility system or just
the one it's the same system okay it's
new heights so this is a a module of New
Heights or why is there a different name
if it's the same thing the system is
already in place if the the differen is
is that we are now having to pay for
this particular service where previously
it was paid for by the center for
Medicaid services but they Chang to that
effective June of
24 okay go ahead um Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer of the Department of
Health and Human Services during the
Senate phase of the budget we um
received additional information from the
federal government that this system
which we were or this particular
component that we were previously able
to use for free now had a cost attached
to it so we didn't have a discussion
about this during the house phase
because that was information that came
in late during the Senate phase a
million dollars was added to the
Medicaid budget because that was our
best
anticipated um guess at that point as
far as where it should fall um and the
Senate added that money into the
operating budget at that phase and then
the function of this particular uh
request here is to move those dollars
into the dees budget because after some
internal conversations we determined
that was where it made the most sense to
budget those funds thank you may I have
a followup followup um okay so so in
this eligibility system is one of the
very specific precise verification steps
including whether or not the person uh
uh requesting eligibility is a legal
Hampshire so that is part of the process
within the eligibility determination
process that we we do establish that um
I can't say that the V the uh this
particular component of the system
verifies citizen R I'd have to look that
up okay so I'd be curious later not
right now on knowing yes or no do is the
it system keeping track of a FL FL that
indicates that the check on legal status
has been made and has been determined to
be yes or
no I will confirm with you where that
lies within the process uh thank you so
much and that it's in the it system that
it that we're storing the data that's
correct all right thank you Mr
chair okay anyone else have any further
questions on the item seeing none I'll
entertain a motion to adopt the item I
so moved
representative Edward moves to adopt the
item second by Senator dallesandro is
there any further discussion seeing none
you ready for the question all in favor
say I I oppose no the item is adopted
we're moving on to now to item two 24230
next
item and I believe the senate had a
one Senator rosenal was well I think a
number of us had question on this but
um I got a very long and thank you mrman
yesterday
complex explanation of how Nursing
Facility rates are
set but I understand that it's a
combination of patient
accurity and
cost and the cost includes clinical
staff but also administrative cost and I
just wondered to what extent having a
higher administrative cost is able to
drive a higher
reimbursement rate and the Corel being
if if a particular facility's
reimbursement is
lower wouldn't that impact their ability
to hire more clinical staff and take
residents thank you for the question um
the way I would describe it is we have a
cost-based methodology that's driven off
a cost report which is somewhat like a
complex tax uh form and the um portion
of Medicaid costs um there in our rules
there are certain limits on certain
costs that we'll recognize I do feel
like this issue in the long term needs
to be Revisited because it's been the
same system for for a long time way
before my time um but basically the
costs uh are within certain parameters
are recognized in the system that and
then there's also the Medicaid portion
of cost and then there's a component
that's related to Acuity we measure
Acuity two times a year when we're
involved in setting the the rate um
usually it comes out for January 1 and
and July
1 um no system of reimbursement is is
perfect that they each have some
strengths and weaknesses I think the the
historical cost based reimbursement is
in many ways like when you were going
through hb2 and and looking at you know
how we try to reimburse you know certain
areas when you don't have any basis of
what the cost it's hard to know whether
you're paying adequate rates I do think
that um you know we've did one piece of
migration this past year um which is the
Acuity measurement we went consistent
with how Medicare does it with respect
to measuring the nursing component but
there are um potentially some incentives
that might be um not exactly what we
want I think though um those are some
things we want to work on over the next
year in terms of you know particular
Ally seeing the number of nursing homes
that are changing ownership hands and
the way that um costs can be stepped up
in that kind of transaction base you
know we want to pres where we have a
good operator we want to preserve them
um and not um you know push them out on
the other hand we want to be careful
direction so we know that some nursing
homes that have changed ownership
haven't had their rates re-evaluated
there's been a pretty long
lag with this transfer and the one we
did I think last month will those rates
now be readjusted or does do these
transfers I not help that
situation they they would help that
situation the only caveat to what I'm
saying is if there's another transaction
not aware of that's in in play but we
have to have a cost report for that
facility the ones that I think have come
up maybe in this past session we're all
past that point where we do have a cost
report we can work with the F I'll
follow up if I could so I I think I've
been on this committee continuously for
12 years and just
yesterday you explained to me that on
the dashboard where the nursing home
uh column is called budget it isn't what
we've budgeted for but it's a number of
licensed beds in the state so I guess my
ask is could the department please
instead of saying the number of licensed
beds tell us what we've budgeted
for uh so we can look at what the census
is versus budget because I know
that the budget neutrality factor is
going to come in there somewhere and
depress
rates the the column that has the number
of beds is the the beds and service the
column proceeding it is the actual the
number of days that we projected was
3398 in the budget um and so we can make
I'm sure we can make a footnote change
to incl thank you thank you Mr chair sen
dandro then Senator line thank you uh
thank you Mr chair first of all Henry
thank you very much for the work that
you spent yesterday helping me out
because we spent almost the whole godamn
day trying to figure out what the hell
was going on and uh thank you because
your perseverance and getting back to me
I truly appreciate Pro the problem that
seems to have manifested itself his
level of expectation was high how did
how did this level of expectation get
out there that these that these nursing
homes thought they were going to get a
significant significant increase where
did that come from because all of a
calls I think um maybe Nathan and I
probably should address that question um
but I think in terms of just the um you
know what was an hb2 was fully um put
into to play and we're actually with the
two transfers we're putting more into
play but I think in terms of what we've
observed in terms of the the draw on the
504 count the the pool of what we fund
through the budget um I think Nathan you
you have some analysis that you've done
there sure
um
so accounting unit 2152 is the
accounting unit through which we make
the the class 504 the nursing home
payments um there's a special class note
in
where at the end of the year if there's
money left over that we haven't spent
then there's the 504 payout um that
won't be happening this year I think
historically that has always happened uh
last may we had to transfer $6.5 million
now we're transferring $8 million
because what we've seen is just in the
past two months after we submitted that
item our final April numbers came in our
final May numbers have come in and
they've been 2.5 million plus higher
than the prior trending 6 months before
that and so we're starting to see an
increase and part of that is due to the
the increase rate so we're we're
starting to see that go up um this year
was unique in the sense that the rate
setting process which I'm I'm assuming
you talked about at at at length
yesterday was impacted partly by um some
of the ownership changes that have have
occurred and some of the reporting that
we received as well and and uh the the
the county and Department um I mean
we've met we've talked about that to
address those kind of issues in the
future and we're trying to implement
controls as well um to keep this to not
have to do transfers going forward in
the future one kind of unique Factor as
well that we've been seeing this year um
we went back and we looked at the
history here in 2022 we had about 3.8
million dollars of back billing um but
because we've seen I think it's I think
it's something like
133% of change of ownership in the
facilities this has led to some
confusion as well as some late back
billing so this year as of the last time
I checked a week or two ago we were at
about $15.5 million of back billing
which which is pretty significant
compared to Prior years um I we're going
to be working with our actuaries for the
the next 2627 budget to try to account
for some of these variables that that
that are uh being affected by the
volatility of the the
ownership it is is one of the problems
the fact that they have many unfill beds
because they can't staff them now I I
talked to one nursing home yesterday and
they have I guess 25 or 30 unfilled they
can't they can't fill the bets because
they can't get people what does that do
to the to to the rate I mean obviously
if you're doing fewer fewer people um
what does that do to to a quick to a
quick fix in terms of how can they how
can they do this without falling into
into deep deficit because everybody
seems to be suffering from from that
that situation there there are many beds
that can't be filled and and the other
aspect that bothers me a little bit is
this change in ownership that seems to
be taking place around around the
circuit mean that happens and and it
sets this whole process back a little
bit because you got to redo this and and
you have to redo that is that is that
what's happening around the country the
there is a lot of um I described as
flipping of of facilities and you know
we we had conversations earlier in the
year about when we get past the session
that you know it's one of the things
that we want to spend some time
evaluating our rules and and our
incentives around that um so I do think
that that's a factor and as I said we
want to we don't want to have
unnecessary churn because it affect it
not only affects the finances but the
people who are who are receiving the
care in the facilities is not Sometimes
the best thing um and so um I think we
have some work to do there and I think
we have some work to do on whether the
current system that we have in in terms
of um the cost based system whether
there are further adjustments we want to
make because the the issue I think that
with a high inflationary period right is
the cost report has to be we use use an
audited cost report which means there's
a lag sometimes of a couple years in
terms of what the costs are you can
understand on a cost BAS system you you
want at least to be able to tie back to
the facilities audit you know Financial
audit so that you know you have numbers
that you can rely on so I think there
are some things that we could do but
under current rules and current state
plan we would have to make some changes
and I think those changes need to be you
know thought out and we have to go
through the the process of you know
interacting with the industry to to get
their thoughts on it because some things
work better for some and others I'm sure
the calls that you got were for the ones
that didn't do as well typically as some
you know some did better than others
sure it the thing that I saw had the
numbers that you gave me yesterday the
variance I mean that's in my opinion
that's fairly significant yes fairly
significant I I don't know I don't know
how that
happens there's got to be that's got to
be looked into I I think because you
can't get that kind of a
variance because you're all delivered
the same service yeah
correct off B the basic service you know
is some comparable but some facilities
take higher Acuity patients and have a
need higher Staff to meet those needs um
so I I would say that we need to look at
this it's not it's not perfect no system
is um but uh you know I think in a high
inflationary period the the lag and
recognizing cost is also I think what
the what the nursing facilities are are
struggling with in terms of trying to
meet current budgets that's a problem
but but I I don't want to anyway let my
colleagues think that you aren't doing
an outstanding job because your response
to me was UN Target we you got to the
basis got right back to me and I got
back to to my constituents the problem I
see is fundamentally how is all of this
going to work out in in in the future
got we got a a serious problem that's
out there that that's got to be dealt
with it it's going to take money
obviously uh to do that but but indeed
uh the Varian has kind of bother me and
and the other the other thing that
bothers me is the pro- share aspect we
were told at a meeting quite some time
ago that the pro proch money was was
going to be huge now only only that the
the uh County nurse sces pick up the
prochi now that doesn't run through you
does it is is that a direct
appropriation or what so um in terms of
uh we used to do proch share through
intergovernmental transfers right and um
the state of New Hampshire would provide
some funding to the to the counties I
think two two years into the change in
proch share we were told that we
couldn't do the loaning if you will of
the money from the from the um from the
state treasury to do that it had to be
independent from the counties we're
still based on other changes we made in
the process we're better off than where
we were but not as good as that the 18
and 19 year um turned out to be um but
what we're doing there is um we use the
cost report again um to now all nursing
facilities benefit from the certified
public expenditure approach which is
whatever the Gap is between what
Medicare would pay and what Medicaid has
paid that um CMS will pay 50% of that
and no money has to be sort of put up
you just make it as a claim in the
process um that particular methodology
in a high inflationary period is is
better because costs are are more
readily uh recog recognize but you know
the the old days if you will of being
able to use the state's money to to
start the transaction just is no longer
considered um in any any uh state to be
approved
methodology so the complexity of the
process is something that we have to
deal with we got to deal with as as we
as as we move forward uh well things
seem to quieten down to some to some
degree but but indeed I'm sure my
colleagues have received the calls uh
and
uh do your best to address them thank
you Mr chair appreciate that so Lang for
a question thank you um so thank you
Henry we've taken my question so again
my my question I think all of us sitting
on my desk right now is from a nursing
home in my in my uh District that is
asking me about a reimbursement rates
and B timing of payments um has there
been a lag in payments going back to
nursing homes and is there is there
systemic reason do it seem like all of
us have a similar problem um that in our
and we were chatting and we've all got
phone calls where either reimbursement
rate or the timing of reimbursements are
problematic I think um on the timing of
payments um there's sort of this uh the
challenge of um meeting what I think you
want us to do which is to make sure that
someone we're paying for is eligible
right and some of that can be um complex
like having to revie view trusts um need
to get information that's not easy for
the beneficiaries to do um and we're
trying to we're we're working on
um changes in our systems and Karen um
who was up earlier oversees the unit
that we're we're working on things to
try to make it easier for facilities and
for case managers to be able to help
their people those things are going to
start to come on I think in the the late
summer early fall in terms of the system
changes that are being made now
to to help them get that the other thing
that we had to do just in terms of you
know processing applications you know we
had to do over 200,000 redeterminations
to since they weren't done for years and
that's the other thing that we're facing
I think you know the public you know we
as a state uh you know again we weren't
perfect but among states we were I think
you know among the leaders in terms of
getting through the process and getting
through it in a as Humane uh way as we
could um but I think that you know we
have a meeting this week with the um the
private nursing home group The New
Hampshire healthare Association uh to
talk about their concerns um we're
trying to address them we've made we're
making adjustments to try to um work
better with them um in the end there
sort of though this there there is this
tension between you know making a
determination when you still need
information and you know to a certain
extent it's better that we sometimes
take longer to work things through
because as long as the application's
open we can go back to the date of the
initial application to pay them if we
deny an application too soon then they
lose that start date um and I know that
the the nursing facilities are feeling
that pressure we're working to try to to
to close that gap down I know they would
like us to be doing it faster than we
are um they have our attention we are
working on things um
um and I guess all I can say is that
that I do think that they're feeling
some of that some of it is just you know
trying to care for the them as well in
the sense that if we close it too early
um you know then they're going to lose
that original date to get paid from and
that's not good
either one quick followup so again so it
sounds like you're addressing it
hopefully how long do you think it'll be
before we have some movement on either
the rate setting or the uh closing the
gap between application and and
reimbursement because to Senator delis
Andre's Point um the longer we don't
reimburse them the less money they have
to pay employees which means they have
less beds available to them and begin we
start this downward spiral that because
they're not getting reimbursed in a
timely manner so I want to be careful we
don't crate our nursing home system yes
I I think that the rate setting is is
we've been on time on that and the rates
will get implemented the issue I think
is is the completion of a of a initial
application
where where we're we've made some
improvement in the average time it's
still you know we have 90 days to
complete what we call a non-mi
application those are ones where we have
to go to bank records and life insurance
policies and so forth versus the ones
that are based like the Magi
applications which are just based on
income those we you know process you
know in a short period of time like
seven days or less in many instances
it's the ones that are the more
complicated ones where we have to look
at you know sale of a home did was it
done you know correctly and all that
that uh we're trying to find ways to do
that part of the system of care that you
um approved last session those have
elements to help them like we just
implemented on January 1 um an ability
to modify the look back period um and
also the asset disregards that were a
part of that you know that those are
things that just are starting to come
into play which I think are leading to
some improvement there's more that we're
going to
do thank you so bir s then Senator Rosen
thank you um thank you Henry for all
your work on this um going back to the
the higher Acuity level are those
nursing homes and have except the higher
acity Acuity level are they getting more
of the pie that that's part of the
factor that drives it there other
factors but that is a factor that you
know if you have more nursing hours
you're going to have more um more
reimbursement and followup follow up um
so how do how do we know which
facilities are accepting the higher
acurity levels so um there's a a a
reimbursement system called um pdpm it's
another acronym to throw out there but
it's a basically patient driven uh
method of assessing the amount of care
that they have in and there's also an
MDS form which is a standard form both
these systems are based off of what
Medicare does for for doing assessing
patients needs and you know more about
that than me yes good morning I'm
Melissa Hardy I'm the division director
for long-term supports and services so
all nursing homes use what Henry
referenced for the MDS at a minimum data
set so it's a clinical assessment for
each patient that's done a admission and
at least quarterly for everybody to
measure nursing needs therapy needs um
psychosocial needs so it's a
comprehensive um Nationwide assessment
that every nursing home
does is there um a way that we can have
access to that information yeah I mean I
think we'd be happy to if there are
people on the this committee or
otherwise to to spend some time with you
and get your perspective after we we
share that um that's something I
certainly offered to to the legislators
it's good over time it's been helpful I
know on Pro share representative spent
quite a bit of time with us to to
understand that we'd be happy to to work
with you I'd like to thank you Rosal for
question thank you
Mr does my questions about that
90day statutory time
limit does that begin when the case is
open
or after the medical
determination is made it's Upon A
completed App application um so that's
part of the the challenge in terms of
When you're counting days the the the
term that people tend to talk about is
pending application that there's a
problem with pending applications
there's pending applications where we
have everything and we don't complete it
within 90 days and under state law if we
have a completed application and we
don't um do our work within that 90 days
that person is deemed eligible whether
we completed it or not the issue is the
ones where we have challenges on um you
know getting records or you know people
get frustrated sometimes where we we ask
for certain Financial records and they
think okay I provided them I should be
done but then based on a look at those
records we may need we may see something
that says we see a transaction
we see a life insurance policy we see
something that tells us we need to look
at something else um and I know that
from our state standpoint we want to
make sure that you know we want to help
those who meet the eligibility but we
don't want to pay for those who don't
and so I think that there's that tension
all the time that we're we're trying to
work through and I know as a as a
provider when you have someone in your
facility you want to be
paid thank
you any further questions on the
item entertain a motion to adopt
24230 motion by Senator Rosal second by
Senator bsel to adopt the item further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I I oppose no the item is adopted don't
four
227 okay 227 is uh Human Services
authorization to budget and expend 2,530
13 and other funds and decreased General
funds by
2025 thank you Senator Rosen thank you
um so I I question this item uh
because the uh Department told us that
some of the other
funds that were supplanting General
funds were OB abatement funds and since
I chair that
commission I am
interested uh we have one
position that supports that OBO de
patment fund that um we've agreed to pay
for with obio payment funds but we don't
know if the
department has ever
transferred the op into batement
in um and I I just want to give a little
bit of broader context for this item I
will answer your question directly
though um the department for the past
several years we've been developing um
we we call it internally just a budget
system and what this new system um that
that recently went live is giving us the
ability to do is to more accurately
identify how we earn funds so those are
federal funds or other funds so you
probably remember two years ago we had a
significant amount of federal funds that
we earned that laps that we didn't spend
because we didn't have the analytics
available to easily identify the where
we earn those funds this new system is
now allowing us to do that and in
concert with that um I've internally
within the division of finance we've
reur some of our existing positions to
act as uh Business Systems analysts to
assign resources to these kind of
functions so we can better utilize the
funds that are
available this particular item um this
is working with exclusively other funds
here U there's Hamstead Hospital opioid
a small amount of opioid about 36,000
something like that medical cannabis and
some ESU dollars here and the purpose of
this is to recog ize the costs that have
been earned and the department has a
public assistance cost allocation plan
it's a several hundred page document and
that document is approved by the federal
government and we use that document to
establish a system of controls for a
cost allocation system so that each
position earns a small piece of what
it's due so to speak so if you look at
um the you know some of the division
directors or some of the commissioner
level positions
there's potentially up to 190 or 200
different funding sources that are
attribute to each of that are attributed
to each of those positions um and the
reason that we do that is to leverage
the dollars that are available this
particular item is dealing with the
other funds and I I checked in with our
staff on um the discussions at the
opioid um
commission and one position has been
established and then a second position
will be established here or it's been
established for we're seeking to um to
hire right now and as part of those
discussions um I believe what was
discussed was the indirect cost so what
you're seeing in this item is those uh
small indirect costs being recognized by
the executive level positions or in
human resources or in doit or in other
areas that support the the work of the
commission I had a conversation this
morning with the deputy AG who
said well only the person who's Staffing
the
commission only that position can
qualify for opioid payment funds no
other administrative or
executive
functions can be
claimed um to be funded by the op raping
Commission
unless the commission votes to expend
those funds in that way which we haven't
so has the department let let me ask the
question again has the department
transferred the funds for the one
position that we did agree to fund with
OPI funds yes I I believe so and and
when I spoke to the finance member that
attended that um her understanding that
that was expressed to the opioid
commission that the dollars would be
used to cover indirect costs through the
plan can I follow up please so last week
the second position got posted I think
it was last week maybe it was the week
before I I it's hard to imagine you're
going to hire someone before June June
30th but that position which has been
posted would not
exist if it were not for opioid de
batement fund so I honestly don't see
how how you
could how the department could
imagine that that position the opiod
funds could offset General funds because
we would never create the
position and yet
all of this 2 and a half million that
you're claiming in other funds is being
put towards the back of the budget cut
to say look we've cut two these $2.5
million towards our $23 million back of
the budget cut but some of these funds
either you haven't been authorized to
spend or you haven't incurred them yet
so so as I said earlier um historically
we haven't had this budget tool
available to us to easily identify those
funds the biggest the largest amount of
dollars here is for Hamstead hospital
for which when we went into the budget
we didn't have a history as far as what
would be earned and that's why we're
seeking to Tre that up here after we
went through this exercise again this is
the first time we've ever done this and
this will be reflected in the next
budget and we also wanted to do this in
advance so that when we're looking at
the base budget uh we have a complete
more accurate year for State fiscal year
24 um that that we move forward with
this before that time frame just for
that purpose after we did that we looked
at the back of the budget cut you'll see
there's the informational item for the
back of the budget cut for that item we
went through every class line that we
had we scrubbed them down to see what
was available what would lapse um to
come up with that figure and then after
performing this analysis we said okay
well if we're going to be writing these
general fund
down why why wouldn't we use those
towards the required the mandatory
required back of the budget cut and then
this this exercise here is consistent
with the cost allocation plan where
we're recognizing those funds that
should be earned so we don't end up in
the same scenario where we did a few
years ago where we lapsed a significant
amount of other and federal funds that
were earned that we didn't
spend i' like to move to table this item
oh I'm sorry I withdraw
that
withdraw all right we'll we'll have
representative Edwards question before
we entertain your motion thank you thank
you for your discretion Senator I
appreciate you holding off on your
motion um I I just had a couple tiny
questions um you were referring to this
um on the front page as the new system
and it's meant to track all expenditures
by source of funds and program I I think
I heard you use a specific name for this
new system is there a specific name for
this new system so that we know how to
talk about it in the future internally
we've just been calling it the HHS
budget system HHS budget system internal
okay um and then uh in the introduction
that sentence it says the department
entered into a contract in April 2022 I
I I don't recall that is is that was
that at the discretion of the department
or was that directed through legislative
action um the contract itself was
approved for governor and executive
Council I'm not talking about approved
I'm talking about who initiated the who
who wanted to do the
contract it was at the Department's
direction to address that sort of
long-term issue that we've had where we
weren't able to accurately identify
where those other or federal funds were
earned midy year and then more
importantly the system will be used in
this year's upcoming budget to more
accurately identify the percentage so
that we can better utilize federal funds
and offset general fund dollars so so
one followup then follow up I I I just
want to uh congratulate you and thank
you I I often don't sound like I'm uh
applauding the work of the department
but I am in this case if you took the
discre or a discretionary action to
create a better internal control system
and it's it's yielding some Pro probable
monies that we can reallocate into the
budget I I just think this is really a
really great management initiative and
uh I want to I want to publicly thank
you and the commissioner and everyone
else that's been involved um and uh and
that's it thank you um representative
Ros this is the last meeting of this
fiscal year so depending on how this is
going to affect the budget Bud for this
fiscal year obviously it's the first
year of bium and the bium hasn't ended
so right that might affect whether we
table this or not because we might want
to finish up the fiscal year as it's
scheduled so move to table okay motion
to table this
item second second further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I I oppos no no all right let's show it
hands all in favor of
tabling one two three four five six7 all
right the item is
tabled thank
you and all opposed obviously it's less
yeah that's
right all
right so we'll now move to the regular
calendar
tab
nine and what do you know Department of
Health and Human
Services
FIS
item seeing none move to
approve Lang moves to accept item 24222
is there a second yes second by Senator
rosenal further discussion seeing none
all in favor say I I oppose no that item
24215 officer consumer Advocate I have a
question Mr
chairman representative lean has a
question to someone here from consumer
morning good morning excuse me good
morning Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm Donald Cree the consumer
Advocate thank you for coming
representative leean has recognized for
a question thank you Mr chairman and
thanks for taking my question I'm just
curious what's in the special um utility
assessment account that you're going to
use to fund this extension or addition
to the contract uh you're curious about
what's in the assessment I'm not
sure the amount of money that's in
the the special utility assessment fund
there is no amount of money there's no
fund uh the special assessment provision
of our enabling statute simply
authorizes me
to
uh uh enter into contracts with
Consultants that are not already part of
my office's budget as long as I bring
that request to you for approval and
then to governor and councel so that's
what I've done
here and all of it all of our all of the
costs of the office of the consumer
Advocate as with the costs of the Pu and
the department of energy are ultimately
uh build to the utilities and the
utilities in turn recover those costs
from customers so essentially the
customers the utility customers whose
interests our office represents
ultimately pay for us follow uh thanks
Mr chairman I guess what confused me is
that in your on the second page it said
the special utility assessment funds if
they're no longer available General
funds will not be used so I that's where
I get somewhat confused it's a third
paragraph in your letter to us in the
event that special utility assessment
I I I don't have a good explanation for
why that sentence is worded that way uh
I work with the business office of the
Department of energy on drafting letters
like this to make sure that they meet
the technical requirements of the whole
process so that's what I did here but
the the explanation I've just given you
is is I'm pretty sure an
accurate characterization of what the
financial realities of the situation are
okay I guess it's a nonrelated question
that this may be out of your realm but
um I know your job is to protect the
consumers and the rates as far as
electrical rates and all the utility
rates we've heard that we're entering a
period that there may be a a number of
hurricanes on the east coast and I was
just curious if you had any comment
whether our utilities are able to handle
a catastrophic event that occurred like
in 1938 when people were without power
for months if you get into that part of
the utilities they prepare to handle
major disasters like that and get power
restored quickly uh we absolutely do get
involved in that and uh I of course I am
not a utility executive myself and I
don't supervise the utilities directly
but they do have all sorts of very
expensive measures in place that are
designed to allow the utilities to
respond rather quickly to uh major
weather related disasters like
hurricanes so it is true that if a
significant hurricane pass through New
Hampshire or the Northeast it would
cause outages in the Electric System uh
we would expect those to be
restored uh in the case of a hurricane I
would say within a matter of a day or
two or three certainly not not weeks or
months okay thank you Mr chairman thank
you Senator dallis Sandra for a question
thank you Mr chairman nice to see you
and as always I love the bow tie thank
you this is my Winston Church bow tie a
classic no question tell I want to ask
you just a key question as a consumer
why are the trans the uh transmission
rates so high and the cost of the
product so low it cost twice as much to
trans transmit that energy to my home
than it does for the energy what what's
what's built into the transmission
costs uh I think that we as a
transmission costs are subject to
Federal Regulations so the Federal
Energy Regulatory Commission is tasked
with overseeing those rates and assuring
that they're just and reasonable within
the meaning of the federal power act and
I think that to a pretty significant
degree the need to conduct the kind of
rigorous oversight that that requires
has been abreg and as a result there are
billions and billions and billions of
dollars being spent on transmission
projects in New England that are that
are really going unreviewed by anybody
my office and my counterparts around the
region are very very uh concerned about
that while we're sitting here there's a
body called uh the pack that is talking
about a project to spend I think it's
something like $400 million rebuilding
the transmission line that connects the
Coos Loop in the North Country to the
rest of the electricity grid I don't
think that project should go forward and
when you multiply that $400 million
project by all of the other similar
projects around the region you start to
understand why we in New England are
paying the highest transmission rates of
anybody in the country it is without a
doubt Senator delandro the most pressing
problem that I think my office confronts
and we're very concerned about that so
it's very astute of you to ask a
question about it I look I look at it
every month and I can't believe it I I
really I can't I can't believe it
because I I I look at that energy cost
and I look at that transmission cost and
I say what what what is what is going on
here uh anyway I I appreciate your
comments on it that's something that
that uh we as a state we now have a
department of energy we should be
looking at that because the burden on
the consumer
for those costs is enormous when you
when you put it all when you put it all
together it's an enormous cost and I I
uh look it polls and wires have all have
always been contentious in the state
right we've been dealing with polls and
W for years and years and years well it
never
ends some somehow some way somebody has
to address that because I think the
consumer is being short changed I hardly
agree thank
you I very seldom get agreement so I
appreciate that very much thank you well
if I might even push my luck even
further Senator dallesandro I was in a
hearing the day that you announced your
retirement so I didn't get to come down
to the state house so I would just like
to salute you on your distinguished
court move to
approve okay motion to approve the item
of the second motion was from Senator
Lang second was from Senator birdell any
further discussion seeing none you ready
for the question all in favor of
adopting the item say I I oppose no the
item is adopted moving on to tab
214 and I people have questions Senator
uh thank you Mr chairman commissioner
great to see you commissioner as always
having been working the budget for a
number of years the the overtime the
overtime and the vacancy rate continue
to bother me uh because the overtime uh
puts a lot of pressure on the
employee and and uh I look at it and
those numbers and dve me PS what 12
billion and another 8 billion that's
amazing that kind of money is being
spent on overtime and you got what a 279
person vacancy rate you have about 700
almost 800 people it's a 26% vacancy
rate now there's got to be uh we we've
got to we've got to address that somehow
some way somebody's got to address that
because that can't that can't go on in
my opinion because the people that that
are working for you they're burning out
they got to be burning out uh working
working all of that over time just uh
and uh I think it creates a difficult
environment I like get a comment on that
I've been looking at this for years you
know and we've tried we've tried
incentives we've tried we've increased
the salaries we've done all of all of
these things and it it U like it it
seems at this point we we're not getting
to where we want to
be so thank you for that question for
the record Helen HKS commissioner of the
Department of Corrections and with me is
Lisa Stone our director of
administration and uh the cost of
overtime uh has increased in general
because of the collective bargaining
process so the hours themselves cost
more um we've actually made great
strides in increasing our recruitment
specifically of Corrections Officers so
when we were at 50% just 6 months ago
we've already dropped that down to 46%
and that actually matters significantly
um the creation of we refer to them as
perdum positions um has reduced the
burden of the overtime uh fill rate uh
from our officers to using these
positions we created from our lessons
learned and using the National Guard so
we are reducing the number of times an
officer is forced into an overtime spot
through use of those resources and
relief pool so the uh comments that you
share about the employee are absolutely
our first and foremost uh concerns
within the agency is reducing that
burden the costs of overtime uh are not
controlled from the perspective that
bargaining did happen and is
appropriately so paying people uh proper
rates for proper service um but we are
making good strides uh post the pandemic
which was a major hit to the
organization in adjusting and improving
our uh acquisition of talent and so for
example right now uh we are at a we've
hired 50 new officers this physical year
um and that's significant our retirement
rate has gone back to what has been
normal for the agency we only had 15
people choose to retire in the last 12
months and my thanks to the to this
committee and the legislature and
affording us the opportunity to continue
to offer that $110,000 incentive through
November so all of the work and that's
outlined in this ask is is making a
difference um and we are improving our
staffing and I just want to reiterate
this is a national Correctional issue
and I participate with the correctional
leadership Association on a recruitment
and retention committee and we are
mindful that even before the pandemic
the Department of Labor forecasted a
significant decrease in Corrections um
and and we're trying to fight that
state listen I Au I authored the
recruitment retened statute that was my
piece of legislation now we can only
have that in place so long uh because
the money is going to run out okay the
money is going to so so indeed there's
got to be something in place that that a
retains people and you seem to be doing
a better job with that because your
retirements are are less now the money
is better the salaries are a better and
so forth but but indeed
this this situation if it
continues you know it's a no wi
situation it and we've got to get
ourselves out of this no win
situation that's that has to happen and
on the plate now is a new prison right
and that so we're talking about a new
prison we're talking about you got 40
billion B in the uh as a legislator
special to build a prison the consensus
I I think that we heard was it's going
to cost maybe 400 million to build a
building to get it all to together I
don't know if that number that never
came about but all all of these all of
these things are leading to a
situation that that we can't we can't
handle it's some way some way somehow
this those controls have got to be put
in put in place people have to be
retained you got to fill the jobs uh and
we've got to have some some maintenance
there some some
predictability and and and some
stability I just think U Future
legislators can't live with it can't
live with the
situation it's got to it has to be
adjusted we have the we we've had these
across the board vacancies in state comp
we've been funding ourselves with lapses
we've been funding ourselves by filled
you know appropriated but not filled
position that's how you get a lapse and
and these 4% lapses can't exist
forever it they just can't in my my in
my
opinion this is this is one that I
really worry about because of the future
so just a point that would it make thank
you Mr J thank you commissioner s Lang
on the item thank you commissioner for
taking my question can you tell me how
many what was the vacancy High rate for
cosos
total number of vacant positions what
what was your high number do you know I
do
know so the high we were at 197 vacant
security positions across the agency and
now we are I should have printed this in
a larger
State excuse
me uh
one forgive me Senator I believe that's
161 but I'm have to reconfirm that um
again I appreciate the sentiments of
Senator delandro but I believe we
provided information to show you that
for years now we've taken this very
seriously and made great strides um and
we're going to continue to do that and
the uh support we've received to replace
the New Hampshire state prison for men
is part of our retention issue again as
I sit comfortably in this room I'm fully
aware and keep in the Forefront of my
mind I have hundreds of staff that are
not sitting comfortably are working
comfortably in a facility that
Foundation was from 1878 and in fact
yesterday when I went there in the
afternoon and walked around and thank my
staff for being there and perspired with
them I can appreciate the support that
we've received to really move that
conversation forward um and I I do want
to take the opportunity as I did in my
capital budget presentation to share
with you we're not just taking strides
with our staff and building Wellness
programs and all of those elements that
are naturally appropriate for the work
we do in Corrections but we're also
looking at the population of people
incarcerated and we're reducing our
recidivism rate in the state from 2018
to now we've dropped that rate from 48%
down to 41% that's a 7% change in the
work that we're doing to help people
stay in New Hampshire communities and
reduce the population incarcerated in
state facilities that also matters we've
continued to keep the second floor of
our Hancock Building closed because our
population has been down reducing 14
posts that we don't have to fill so
we're very mindful and balanced in the
work that we're doing and building those
bridges to the New Hampshire communities
to help people stay out and if they're
not appropriate to stay out they do come
back um and we continue to work and
improve that process um as I affirmed on
Tuesday our women's facility has made a
difference in that recidivism rate it's
no surprise to me that women in New
Hampshire have a lower recidivism rate
than men and some of that is due to the
fiscal plant changes so again thank you
for the support and I affirm for you we
continue to work on this
issue so you were talking about I'm
highly concerned like sen delandra
overtime right especially forced
overtime in a Corrections Facility where
it's going to create higher burnout
rates for our cosos um you were talking
about a pum system that was put in a
place can you just briefly tell me about
that because I I could see where that
would dramatically help your um overtime
problem yeah thank you Senator we um
again learned from our experience with
the National Guard in in creating and
training people to work in our non-armed
control rooms um so what we did is uh so
that we do not have to lean on the
National Guard in the future is created
a a a non-benefited uh relief pool of
prum employees um it's done two things
for retirees who did not want to
maintain their certification as officers
they've come back and filled those
positions and we've drawn in a new group
of individuals whom they're on an actual
system where they get a text saying we
have posts available and they
voluntarily sign up for those posts um
and that happens across all of our
facilities it's been working really
great um and it again it creates an
opportunity not to force an officer to
work in a post where we really want our
certified Law Enforcement Officers to be
working in the housing units and doing
that uh uh Frontline work uh with those
incarcerated it's it's a great system
and it's working really well thank you
thank you further
discussion representative lean for a
question thank you Mr chairman I did
have just one one question on the
retention mapping under technology it
says RFID what is
that uh thank you for that question RFID
is a type of technology so that we can
get off paper so currently right now
when we do a literal count of people in
housing units we go around and we our
officers are literally checking paper
and making sure 64 people or 64 people
are there this allows us to put
technology in the hand hands of our
officers and um scan IDs uh to affirm
that that person is this person and we
can more quickly do our work more
efficiently thank you thank you Mr
chairman thank you further discussion on
the item move to approve Senator Lang
moves to approve item
24214 and Senator blazedale second
further discussion seeing n you ready
for the question all in favor say I I
oppos no the item is adopted thank you
thank
you
I did I say blaz Del I said we were
giggling over
here know her for 20 years so uh I will
now recognize senator birdell who has a
question of a previous item one of the
previous items um from I can I have um
Deputy
Commissioner from
HHS it's not it's not it's not in the
present agenda it was something that was
removed last last month from the agenda
thanks for um Coming Up um I wasn't here
last month and I understand that the the
I agenda item for the um pilot payment
for Hamstead was taken off as a late
item um has there been any up any been
any update on
that great good morning uh Marissa hen
Deputy Commissioner at DHHS um thank you
for the question Senator and um the best
I can say is just uh to refer all your
questions to the governor's office and
that's uh that's what we can share today
uh our Chief Financial Officer can
provide any more history but that's
that's all I can share at this time well
and I will add that uh Senate Bill 311
is going through the system I have
attempted to contact the governor's
office to have a conversation with him
um
as well as the select board and the
state reps I contacted him on Tuesday I
have not heard back um I understand that
you have meetings with him on Mondays if
our the commissioner does if you could
relay that message to him that we have
reached out to him to try and contact
him thank you uh we absolutely do that
okay tab
24223 the uh Department of
administrative services are there any
questions on this
item second Senator bird El most to
approv Senator Lang seconds is there any
further discussion seeing none you're
ready for the question all in favor say
moving on to informational material is
there any that anyone on the committee
wishes to question
HHS the dashboard I guess dashboard the
closest really
um a question about the
dish
226 Dash thank you Mr chairman um I had
another great conversation the other day
with Mr lman who seems to work late into
the night and I thank you for
that so you told me that the
department is working on rate
increases for the hospitals that would
take place by September 1st so this
morning when I came in I rad the letter
from the governor
dated undated undated that said um that
no more than
80% of the Met would be returned to
hospitals in any form form of dish
payments or rate increases or any other
kinds uh I think you and I discuss that
that equates to about $35 million a year
cut to hospital so I just my question is
the these rate
increases are not going to mitigate the
$35 million a year cut they're just
going to redistribute
some of them met from the way we've been
years so in in terms of
the the way that it's I think the
governor's um letter is directing the
the commissioner we're working on a plan
that would um I think from a policy
perspective start the shift away from
Dish um which we're expecting
uh State reductions um all states are
but New Hampshire is expecting a fairly
significant reduction and what we're
going to be able to pay in dish in the
future um so I think the the plan
Governor's plan that and commissioner's
plan that we're working on um will have
less less dish but you're right in terms
of the um 80% if you based that on this
year's met tax which was
39.2 would be about about $255 million
that 255 would be um you know put in a
way that would um support
the um if you will the best that we can
do in terms of um improving rates for
hospitals um and uh through either
direct rates or through the directed
payment mechanism and it would be less
dish but the you know the pool of money
that's available to pay out is 80% of
the uh in this current year by example
we had uh we paid up 220 million in dish
in in Dish and then the balance to
29.4 which is 91% of the the 319 tax
that the 220 plus um the payments and
supplemental and directed payments we
made to critical access hospitals equal
but so no matter how you slice the
pizza um we're still talking about
basically this fiscal year a 35 million
cut to hospitals you'll just be paying
it out differently it won't be all in um
uncompensated care some will be in Sub
payments not increasing the size of the
pie the pi will be from 290 using this
year's met tax would be 290 versus 255
but the the the benefit of putting into
rates and directed payment is that um
all from September one assuming
governing Council approval of the
contract would be from September 1 you
know all the way up till the time that
they would pay their tax in um in April
um they would be getting um you know
higher rates um they do then pay the tax
in April um but the Dish payment is
likely to be
lower thank you thank you Mr chairman
Senator dandro then representative
Edwards oh thank you thank you ju just
for clarification H the dish payments
have been made for this year correct
okay and the money has been returned to
the hospitals correct so the deal ends
this month it's over the six-year deal
that's in place is over so the real
problem begins when monies are due in
April for what what's going to what's
going to be there and right now there's
nothing there we we' seen
proposals by the Senate sen Bradley's
proposal I I think that there was some
communication with with the house but
but at the present time I think people
should understand it's done for this
year the payments have been made the
payments have been returned to the
hospitals the six-year deal is over so
there's nothing in place from from this
point on it's it's negotiations so
either we either have to create it
legislatively or this letter this uh
letter that went to the governor or went
from the governor to the commissioner
grants to the commissioner total
authority to go to CMS and ask for plan
change
correct so I I think that's the current
statute
16764 um when had the payment terms
through 2024 and thereafter that what
you said is correct in terms the
commissioner has discretion in terms of
the the plan um in terms of how to use
the the tax money so in
and I say this to my colleagues the
legislature has been taken out of the
process legislature has no role at this
point in time Governor has said to the
commissioner you will go to CMS ask for
a change in the plan and you will ask
your your staff to create an 80%
deal that's that's what's led the table
as we speak now we legislated an
arrangement Senator MO
I was a party to that to some extent but
not to any great but president Mo in the
legislature negotiated this six-year
Arrangement that that proved nobody's
happy all the time but at least it was
satisfactory now we have a situation
where legislature is totally out of the
picture and unless you have a special
session or you re or or or reconvene for
some reason in January there's nothing
in place in and my question to to Henry
is does does the or do the hospitals
have to accept this new Arrangement that
you you're working on by virtue of that
deban by the governor it go it just goes
to the
hospitals I mean that's that's not
that's not the legislative process no it
isn't that's that's totally disregarding
the legislature and the legislator's
ability to work this out and we all
represent hospitals y all right there
are there are critical access hospitals
that will be impacted severely and there
will be hospitals that will be impacted
significantly and that's the public that
we're talking about the public is served
by these
hospitals think of this it we look at
this deal was as a result of a lot of
Court action and so forth and so the
those of us who were here remember the
court Rec recognize that but we're we're
faced with nothing at this point time
the legislature has been totally totally
left out of the picture I guess it was
up to the legislature realizing that the
six-year plan was
expiring I was not aware of it but if we
were we should have done something
earlier so it could it could be the law
now right well no question conversations
have been going have been ongoing yep
ongoing for a long period for a long
period of time it it this is as I I said
I'm not going to be here so so uh you
know there there's no burden on my
shoulders but those of you that are
coming back got to figure this out Y and
as I
said there are 15 critical access
hospitals that will be affected there
are Major Medical centers that will be
affected we're talking about a ton of
money a ton of money I mean the tax rep
was what three 319 million point2 is
what the department received from
Dr and I mean just and I say to my
colleagues think about that y because we
we we have a
responsibility we've got a
responsibility people elected us to
serve them the best possible fashion th
this is something I've never seen before
I've never seen anything like this
before really bothers me at this at at
this point in time to see this this
happening uh and uh We've made we' made
big strides look at we talked about the
first year we had a budget that we
everybody loved everybody passed it we
were dancing in the streets the first
year and we're hanging ourselves in the
second
year doesn't doesn't make any sense to
me just doesn't make any sense it as I
said to my colleagues who are coming
back you got to face this y thank you Mr
CH thank you for your work represent Ed
uh thank thank you I I I had another
point I wanted to make but in um in
response to the Senator's comments I I I
just wanted to say as a member of the
commit a conference that dealt with this
issue at the last minute um I I apply
Senator Bradley for all the work he did
trying to bring the hospitals together
with the department and and and with
with the other Senators uh unfortunately
that process had trouble getting over
the U goal line because the the the
house process had been left out of it no
no the the house committees the policy
committees Finance Committees of the
house never had an opportunity to see a
regular bill so at the end of the day we
were asking four rep Representatives out
of 400 to basically cut a deal at the
last minute without having been involved
and so so I I I think the legislature
can do and needs to do a better job but
but there's something in place the the
the the commissioner has a a a directive
from the governor to put together a plan
and to and to work it out and I think
that's uh what's being done I so I I I I
don't want because the department is
sitting in front of us I don't want it
to look to the public like the
department has let us down I think we
just sort of uh didn't get it we didn't
get it done when it needed to get done
and and that's on us but um the um the
thing I wanted to can I go to my main
point certainly uh thank you and this
this may be uh for Dr hen uh in part um
but um
there's been discussion
about H I'm talking about item
226 the statistical summary I I I don't
know what the process is that we use to
add a table or add information to a
table well you know to formally request
one but I would really like to see a
proposal from the Department to add a
table to the statistical document here
that gives us a nice snapshot of what's
going on at Hamstead and
obviously we've got uh patients we're
seeing we've got vacancies we're trying
to fulfill and then we have the issues
with the local community and and calling
in emergency services on an ad hoc basis
and and that third component is is
really important for the legislature to
have visibility on because it obviously
is a Hot Topic in that community and
drives things like uh fiscal requests to
transfer money and to solve
infrastructure problems and it you know
causes us to know whether we should be
supporting the payment in Li of taxes so
so I would like if you could uh develop
and propose a table that would be a nice
Hamstead snapshot and I've mentioned
like three things that could be in it
but but I'll leave it to you you're
you're the PhD um the uh I don't know if
table 12 intends to already try to
capture that somehow but as I'm reading
the columns I'm not seeing a Hamstead
column so
um uh uh thank you for the for the idea
and the recommendation and I'll just
note that under um Senator bird cell's
leadership the YDC impact commission um
we've been able to bring together a lot
of key players in better analyzing this
data to understand the impacts to the
town incl including um as you know uh
visits by by police and First Responders
which I may Note have um knock on would
uh reduce significantly as we seek a
period of stability so I think what I
hear you asking for is to is to show
that data and um one of the things
Senator Bell has encouraged us to do is
to work as a department with the local
First Responders to make sure we're
essentially counting the same units and
agreeing on a methodology there so as
soon as we uh come up with that
methodology this summer would be happy
to uh put together some options thank
you Senator gon thank you um and I I
haven't forgotten the fact that I I need
to contact the chief of police to make
sure that you guys get together
to connect so that you have the same
numbers okay and we should also consider
that the alternative is that the YDC
would have to provide its own security
force and that would be far more money
than what we're asking
be to be given to Hamstead so keep that
in mind if if we're not going to get
that payment to Hamstead then we're
going to request a security Force at the
YDC so so Mr chair if I may I because
I've been struggling to make sure the
community understands the distinction
that the YDC is a separate entity from
Hamet hospital and although they're
co-located to share Services we've
already designed or intended to design
the YDC with the man power necessary to
provide their own internal security the
issue is we're putting it next to
Hamstead Hospital which has come under a
rash of of issues over the last 15
months and so so if we have to beef up
the internal security of one of those
facilities it would be Hamstead not yet
the YDC because we've not seen the
Personnel plan for YDC yet thank
you further discussion Senator rosenal
thank you I'd like to follow up on
Senator Dallas 's comments I mean I
think we've known since
2018 that the settlement on the Met was
going to expire at the end of this
month um
is I thought about this term as it being
one of the two major things we had to
accomplish the other one being
reauthorizing Medicaid expansion we got
that done
last fall we started having
conversations within the senate
about the need to get something in place
and at that time the
governor said apparently that he wanted
the Attorney General to put together a
small working group to make progress on
this I I don't know if that ever
happened I was not part of it
um it would have obviously been better
if negotiations had proceeded in time
for a late filed bill that would meet
the deadlines but they didn't so as
often
happens and is consistent with both
Senate and House
Rules uh an amendment was put onto a
house bill that was Germaine because it
was in the Senate version I wish I had
been part of these negotiations I wasn't
I thought the plan the Senate sent over
was reasonable but I I just I mean there
have been times where we've inserted
policy into House Bill 2 during
Committee of conference where nobody's
had a public
hearing and so I don't think that
sending um the dish settlement over on a
house bill
was um very unusual from the way the
legislative process happens but but all
that being said I think a $35 million
cut a year to hospitals well we know
that at least 17 of the 26 hospitals are
going to be in the red is really
problematic for the people who live in
New Hampshire because hospitals are the
backbone of our health care System they
um are responsible for a lot of the
outpatient care as well as the inpatient
care and they're also huge employers and
they have the inability to move so they
can't pick up and move we need them
they're spread all over the North
country and western New Hampshire and
I'm very concerned about the impact of a
$35 million a year cut and that
considering that just this year when
we've gotten the tax payment from the
chairman thank you further
discussion representative Edwards so so
the four out of the 400 were really
close to the what the Senate position
turned out to be we were 5.72 million
apart which was not too bad given the
fact that we've been left out of the
policy and finance part of the process
it just sometimes things just don't
happen and and this was one of those
times where the legislature failed and
if we want to come back if you're coming
back next year and I'm back next year
I'd be happy to to to do a bill uh we
have Senator Bradley's work to draw from
better further
discussion Senator
d i I think the representative remarks
consistent we got to do
better but I represent one of the larger
hospitals in the state 2,000 employees
uh in Manchester 2,000
employees a negative economic impact on
the institution that I'm represent has a
devastating effect of those employees
but what about the people we serve in
the immediate area now we had a six-year
deal in
place I mean there wasn't anybody in
this legislature who didn't understand
when the deal expires the deal
expires I was not made aware of it well
those who worked on it were certainly
aware of it and
U I I I think uh it's in
on on us it's incumbent upon us to bring
this issue forward why couldn't it have
extended I I I wasn't I wasn't part of
the process
uh I think the fact of the matter is
it's getting all kinds of noise now yeah
all kinds of noise and that that's not
not good for the hospitals it's not good
for our
constituents it it it makes us look bad
in the Public's View and I think that's
terrible we have the third largest
legislative body in the englishspeaking
world and we can't get anything
done 400 members of the House 2 members
of the of the Senate it in this issue as
my colleague to pointed out look
at look at the people uh that affected
by
this I think it's I think it's quite
dramatic to be honest with you and and
there's an ongoing dietr between between
the executive and I don't know who at
this point time because it's a mystery
it's it's it's the hospitals that that
that isn't that isn't helping anybody
all the problems we've discussed are as
a result of ridiculous
inflation until something is done about
that these problems will persist well
just uh good luck that's all I have to
say yeah Senator Rosal thank you I
actually asked if we could just extend
the current program and was told that we
couldn't because the Federal Regulations
around dish have changed so we really
didn't have better options but now we're
faced I think with something that is
potentially damaging to
people um and could wind up in more
litigation that we've already
lost which led to the settlements in the
first place having been involved with
the me since its
beginning all the money that came in
from me all went back to the hospitals
they were happy we got a match from the
feds we got to spend it as we wanted
then
we were giving it back to the hospital
all of it and then the
hospitals because of the MMS said wait a
minute you can't pay them back for this
because they didn't cross this te or Dr
dot this eye or whatever they their
rules we were giving them back too much
so that's when we had to reduce it
because of the federal
rules so that was what tied a lot of it
up and it's the same thing again when we
try to say give us the money and the tax
we'll give it back to you the feds will
match it we'll all be happy the feds
won't match it if they if they say you
shouldn't have paid them back for this
that's where the problem came from is
from the feds so Senator Lang thank you
Mr chair again I'm not going to look
backwards because we can't do anything
about what's already happened we only
look forward and I'll just remind um all
of us that it's not uncommon for us to
look at beo day and come to an agreement
by VTO day um if you remember a couple
of years ago we did that for we in out
an energy crisis and we're in the middle
of Co and people had no jobs and we
ended up putting $36 million aside to be
able to help people keep their lights on
so it doesn't mean it's closed for the
year if people are willing to sit down
and work we can bring a bill forward on
veto day if we can suspend the rules and
move it forward so I just it it's not
necessarily completely dead um but it's
going to take a willingness of everyone
to sit down and have conversation and
get to a solution that can be dealt
within one day on veto day so and
remember the Senate has more flexib
ility in introducing legislation than
the house has so we'll rely on my
colleagues over on that side again but
it it goes back to Senator Edward's
point that there's policy committees and
fiscal committees that want to have an
input and conversation in this and then
if it doesn't do us any good at the
Senate int does wave the rules and
introduces something only to have the
house say no we're going to do the same
outcome as the commedia conference we're
going to kill it because we don't want
because we weren't involved so I all I'm
saying is I want to remind the issue is
not necessar dead there is an
opportunity forward to go forward and we
should try to look I know I have my
Hospital in my a couple of my hospitals
in my area are losing money on on this
deal right so again I I'm eager to see a
solution go forward um that that that is
good um because again when our hospitals
don't have the money they need to
operate all of our constituents suffer
so we need a solution for this and not
and not just be angry because I wasn't
involved or we anything else so thank
you further
discussion it takes more than just the
legislature to play in this game yes
yeah the the information should have
been brought to
us with some urgency but it wasn't so do
we have anything further in the
miscellaneous items that people would
like to discuss seeing none then the
next item would be to choose our next
meeting we're coming toward the end of a
fiscal year which ends in in just a few
days so we've done all the
rearrangements for all the Departments
where they wanted to balance their
budget and that's been a big part of our
last two months so that should have been
settled um going forward we don't always
meet in July and we don't always meet in
August ask the the commissioner of
administrative Services if he thinks
there would be anything pressing in
uh the first two months of the fiscal
year are better um I don't know of
anything pressing that might come up the
only thing I would tell you is that
something pressing might come
up if it does but I don't know of
anything right now but I there's
certainly no uh the the legislature is
historically skipped at least one of
those two meetings without everything
falling apart um I maybe you could
consider I don't want to tell you what
to do U maybe you could consider not
doing one of the meetings and uh and
waiting to make your mind up on whether
later so I don't want to get in trouble
with other agencies who go well you just
told me they didn't have to meet and now
I got a thing we will we will
tentatively with the permission of the
of the committee I suggest we skip July
tentatively set a date in August but if
we don't hear enough to have a
meeting then we'll cancel August and
probably plan as one of my colleagues
pointed out everybody should be around
by September 10th for the for the
primary so if we have it within that
next the week following the primary we
should have everybody here even those
that wanted to take vacations and be
miles away and not not attend um that
that may work so tentatively what would
be the date in August if we went
September 13 uh so the August date if
tentative August would the third Friday
is August 16th and then September if you
do the Friday after primary would be
September 13th so the date again in
August would be 16th 16th
so let's set a tentative date for August
16th with the possibility that within
the week before or perhaps further than
that out than that I will notify you if
there is no
meeting 10
a say that again 10 a.m 10:00 a.m. as
usual and if we don't have any air
conditioning we'll rely on the on the
Senate to host us again in an air
conditioned
room so
appreciate
it and yours as
well so tentatively August 16th if uh
there's not enough items to that have an
urgency um we may go
to September
13 is that is that approved by all in
favor say I oppose no I guess that works
out so thank you all uh enjoy the rest
of your
summer and I look forward to seeing you
September motion to adjourn is there a
second second by Senator Lang all in
favor say
I those no thank you all for your
attendance thank you all for your good